what prompted you to move into the realm
of television
well i had actually moved into
television before beauty and the beast
one of my novels was uh was a novel
called armageddon rag
which came out in 1983 i believe
and it was optioned for a feature film
by a man named phil degare
feature film was never made but phil did
do a couple drafts of the screenplay and
he uh
unlike most other people in hollywood
who have optioned my prose work
phil wanted my input so he flew me out
to los angeles and we had
we had numerous meetings as he was
commencing the project
and in that way i got to know phil
deguire and a couple years later it
turned out that phil was the executive
producer in charge of the revive
twilight zone
and since we had this um ongoing
professional relationship already he
hired me to do a script just one script
on a freelance basis
and uh they liked it well enough that
pretty soon i found myself
on staff at twilight zone as a as staff
writer
and then a story editor in its last
season and a half and that was how i
began in television
when beauty and the beast came up which
was a year after the
demise of the cbs version of twilight
zone
essentially my agent just sent around
some samples of my twilight zone work
and they liked what they read and
hired me what exactly did you do on
beauty and the beast well i was a writer
producer my primary function was writing
and working with other writers
you know writing my own scripts but also
conducting pitch sessions with freelance
writers
hiring freelance writers to do scripts
supervising them through rewrites and
and so forth and so on and then as i
became a producer you know you also deal
with your script all the way through the
production
process uh casting the shows working
with a director
working with all of the technical
departments the uh you know the prop man
and the special effects man and uh going
over things like that and uh
toward the end i was also involved a
little in post-production
beauty and the beast had a very strange
history was cancelled i believe
once and came back by popular demand no
that's
really not uh accurate there's a sort of
a legend to that effect
but it was put on hiatus at the at the
end of the second season
we ran two full seasons and
partial third twelve show third first
two seasons were 22 shows each
at the end of season two cbs couldn't
find a suitable space for us on the fall
schedule
they actually did offer the production
company which was with thomas
productions
tony thomas and paul wint they did offer
them a space
on saturday night which would have given
us a full third season
but paul and tony turned it down because
it was a time slot opposite
paul and tony's other show golden girls
and they had no intention of competing
with themselves
on rival networks so when we turned down
that slot cbs says when we had no slot
for you but we'll order 12
shows and we'll bring you back as a
mid-season replacement
um some of the beauty and the beast fans
have kind of
encouraged this legend that the show was
cancelled and they wrote a million
letters and demanded that it be brought
back
and they did indeed write a million
letters i don't want to put down their
their dedication love to the show but
essentially all the decisions were made
the same day
the day that we wouldn't be on the
schedule
the decision was also made that we would
get an order for 12 shows and we would
come back as a mid-season replacement
i'm sure many of your listeners are
familiar with star trek and star trek
fandom
which was probably the original
television fandom and grew out of
science fiction fandom and
consisted a number of active science
fiction fans who loved the old star trek
show and waged
that famous campaign after it was
cancelled that resulted in it coming
back for third season
that was really probably the first
really active
fandom sub-fandom devoted to a
television show
but since then almost all science
fiction fantasy genre television shows
generate some kind of fan activity
um fiction scenes uh so forth and so on
even independent conventions there have
been
several beauty and the beast conventions
and beauty and beast is frequently a
secondary attraction
at some of the star trek conventions so
there's a lot of overlap actually
between
star trek fandom and beauty and the
beast fandom
beauty and the beast in its third year
changed
they killed off linda hamilton what kind
of role did you have in
the uh the final changes of beauty and
the beast i certainly had a voice in
them
essentially what happened is linda
hamilton left the show
she wanted to have a baby and she didn't
want to
continue in her role as catherine
chandler
so the writers on the show were faced
with the decision of of how to handle
that
and at that time we were staffed by ron
coslow who was the creator of the show
and uh
the still the executive producer and
myself and
uh writing two writing teams alex gantz
and howard gordon and
linda campanelli and shelly moore so
numerous people for writing units uh as
they call them in hollywood
and we had long meetings about it you
know the decision was do we recast
do we just haven't hire another actress
to show up to play catherine chandler
or do we um do something with the
character and and
try to deal with this uh we
decided not to recast because it has
seldom been done successfully in
television
television viewers tend to identify the
actor very strongly with the role
they can't seem to imagine uh another
actor in the role it's
it's uh in some ways unfortunate that
television people are like that but
certainly you know
in plays millions of actors play the
same role i mean how many people played
hamlet over the
over the centuries uh in movies we've
had
what four james bond now five if you
count the woody allen version
but recasting is very difficult in the
context of television
and we decided there was more dramatic
opportunity if we killed the character
of course that created vast controversy
which endures to this day
but we knew the job was dangerous when
we took it what can we say
what happens when a tv show goes off the
air as beauty and the beast has gone off
and seems somehow to have it i don't
want to use the term
zombie-like but it has some sort of
ghostly continuation beyond its own
lifetime
well some shows do not all shows
certainly ours does seem to have that
i've always felt that beauty and a beast
like the original star trek
is going to endure one of the things
that you've spoken of in the past
concerns censorship on television in
ways in which
you or your staff was kept from doing
what they wanted to do can you talk
about that a little
two different issues here we had a fair
amount of freedom on being in a beast i
don't
i don't think we were s censored to
speak of i i have
had my problems both on twilight zone
and on beauty and a beast with
standards and practices and let me let
me talk come back to that i'll talk
about that a little bit
but that's relatively minor stuff the
censorship that really disturbs me is
the stuff that's going on with the
reruns
the family channel which has purchased
the family channel as you know is the
former christian broadcasting network
and i think there's still a christian
broadcasting network under a clever
plastic disguise uh they still run the
700 club and pat robertson and stuff
like that
they're a basic cable operation they
come free with your cable channel
they purchase the right an exclusive
right to run beauty and a beast for
uh a year before we go into general
syndication
so since our cancellation last uh a year
ago january
they have been the the only one doing
this show
now we knew that they were going to edit
these shows when they go into
syndication they'll be edited even more
but i find the way that the shows have
been edited on
the family channel to be objectionable
uh we knew they would have to cut a
minute two minutes
whatever the time is i'm not sure out of
each show to make room for extra
commercials
you're allowed in in reruns the fcc
rules allow you to do more commercials
and of course if it's allowed
they'll squeeze it in for every book
generally what's being edited though
are some of the finer things about the
show like the poetry that vincent would
occasionally read
many of the poetic references and the
things like that are are snipped out
uh also we did not have a whole lot of
sex in our show
it was deeply romantic show but hardly
uh a sexual hotbed but occasionally uh
some minor characters would be seen in
bed together or would be implied that
some sort of
sexual relation all of that stuff is
gone of course as being objectionable
but all the violence have been left in
so you know you won't if you watch the
show temptation for example you won't
see the scene where
joe maxwell and the guest star of that
episode are
in bed together with a sheet coming
coming up to uh
covering most of their chests you won't
see that because they're obviously naked
under that blanket there and they've
they've done the dirty deed but you'll
see all of the episodes and all the
shows where vincent eviscerates people
and tears them to bits
beyond that editing of individual shows
the family channel has also chosen
to omit certain shows entirely
in the first season we did a show called
dark spirit it concerned
voodoo the show was not rerun at all by
the family channel
they looked at it from a christian
perspective and object to their voodoo
now the voodoo people in the show are
villains
uh so exactly what they object to i have
i have no idea i mean this is a
a crazed group of uh
of voodoo practitioners
doing terrible things but nonetheless
the show is the show is gone
even more disturbing there was a second
season's show which i
co-wrote with a minneapolis writer named
robert john guttke
and it's called when the bluebird sings
and
it's one of our gentlest least violent
and most popular shows
show that the fans particularly love the
show was also omitted from the family
channel because it
contains a character who may be a ghost
who may not be a ghost that you did it's
very clearly written so it's on the
fence you know you can make your own
decision
was he a ghost was he a fraud pretending
to be a ghost
you don't know but it's still enough
that the suggestion of the occult was a
the family channel felt would be
objectionable to their christian viewers
and that show was also dropped from a
running schedule
the most amusing
and dramatic decisions of all of course
concerned the third
season for those of you who haven't
watched a show
basically when uh when we knew linda
hamilton was leaving
we had to write her out of the show and
the plot line that was used in a
two-parter called
lovers be lost has uh has catherine and
vincent
finally getting sexually involved
catherine becomes pregnant she's
kidnapped by a villain
who waits until the baby is born kills
her and then kidnaps the baby
and vincent spends most of the third
season searching for his
son who he finds out has existed and
also
of course looking for the man who killed
catherine to uh to avenge her
but his main concern is recovering his
son
well the first thing family channel
announced was that
they were going to edit in a wedding
ceremony
for katherine and vincent using
stock footage and outtakes
how they were going to do this i don't
know i mean i'm quite familiar i was
there for all three years i saw every
foot that we
shot and printed you know there was no
wedding ceremony between catherine and
vince or anything approximating it
but maybe they would have been able to
do something like this by taking
a snippet here a snippet there a few
close-ups of voice over
but ron koslow the the creator of the
show very quickly put a stop to this
this is nonsense and you don't have the
right to do it and you certainly you
know you have the right to edit the
shows
we can't stop you doing that but you
certainly don't have the right to insert
any new material
so there would be no wedding ceremony at
that point
the family shadow announced that they
were going to edit
out all references to this illegitimate
child
from the third season shows now that one
also really cracked us up because if you
added all references to the
illegitimate child out of the third
season shows you have no third season
shows
you have hour-long shows that are going
to run about 10 minutes
not only that but the complete driving
force of the entire plot
is gone i mean these stories will become
absolutely
incomprehensible what is he looking for
uh so we were looking forward to seeing
how they did that with great amusing and
amusement but uh finally someone there
realized they couldn't do that either
so they chose to drop the third season
entirely
and not to broadcast any of the third
season shows because they contain this
disturbing element of
of an illegitimate child and out of
wedlock
sex this has all annoyed me i know
i've had this argument people say it's
not censorship since they're not
a government installation they're
they're uh private uh
person they've purchased it and it's
equivalent to
you know some little lady who doesn't
want to sell playboy at her
at her card shop but i don't accept that
equivalent i mean
if if an individual proprietor doesn't
choose to sell playboy at their little
shop you can still buy playboy down at
the corner newsstand
but the family channel bought an
exclusive
franchise here they controlled our shows
no one else could show them in the
country
and so with their decision as to what
not to show
they're effectively denying the ability
of those shows to be
seen at all by anyone at least during
the period of their exclusivity
we're talking about censorship now you
raise the fact that the issue that
sex is censored out whereas violence
is left in i have heard this complaint
many times from different sources
and i find it extremely puzzling to me
why would why would violence be okay but
sex not
don't ask me to explain that if i
understood it i'd
be a lot happier man and that is the way
it is
in television it probably says something
about our country and i suspect it says
something very unfortunate about our
country frankly
the other part of the censorship thing i
was going to get to that ties in a
little with this is this
this whole question of censorship
actually when we're making the shows
we actually didn't have many of that so
i don't want to come down on that we we
had pretty much a free hand
especially in the second season and
beyond
all networks have sensors which have
various names they're usually called
standards and practices
these days and the word sensor having
acquired unfortunate connotations
but because of budget cuts at most of
the networks the the
the sensors no longer censor all of the
shows they don't have the manpower to
review them all
so what happens is a new show gets a
sensor on it for the first season
and so that was when we had all of our
all of our fights and they usually came
down to uh
questions about sex violence or language
and we went through this both on
twilight zone and then later on
on beauty and the beast you know they
count dams and hells
so yeah i mean you get these you get
these call where you have 10 dams
and three hells i'm sorry that's 13
that's uh we only permit 10 per hour
so you have to cut two dams in a hell
pardon me are you making this up is this
hyperbole or does this literally happen
this literally happens i have mixed
feelings about the whole issue of
violence which of course in television
terms is called action
you know at the same time the standards
and practices people are saying
there's an unacceptable level of
violence in their shows
and you're getting that from them the
network programming people
are saying your shows are too dull we
want more action
so you have to give them action without
violence
and you know since action is violence
action is just network talk for violence
this is a difficult thing partly i agree
that american television is too violent
how many dramatic shows can you recall
seeing in which when no one dies
violently well
it's hard to think of any you know
american television uses death as an act
break
it's an excellent act break but our
second season when when beauty and the
beast was riding high and we we had some
very good ratings
that buys you freedom and we were able
to do some shows that were pure
character pieces that were not violent
at all
and those are in some ways or some of
the shows that i'm i'm most proud of
that's why there's a real irony about
the censoring of bluebird that was one
of the best shows we ever did
and it's not violent at all vincent
didn't tear anyone to bits
if you're going to portray violence i
think you should portray it honestly
i have real problems with the attitude
of standards and practices and
and the networks in general that they
want lots of violence
but they don't want it to be ugly it
leads to uh
almost a glorification or prettifying of
violence where you're not allowed to
show
the the consequences you're not allowed
to show that death is ugly
you're not allowed to make it shocking
or unpleasant i mean if i'm going to
portray death on screen
if that's what they insist on to get
their shows the action
i want death to be ugly i want to show
the grief that follows it
i want to show the emotional pain i want
to shake
the the people at home up a little and
that's precisely what they don't permit
and their things are just you know very
arbitrary
i mean not only dams and hells some of
the things are the standards and
practices things are just ludicrous
we had one show called china moon before
i get to china moon they count bodies
we had an earlier show called no way
down in which there was a gang war and a
storefront full of gang people were
blown up and there was a line in the
script
you know catherine arrives on the scene
and they said there's something like
four bodies
covered by sheets lie in the street and
you know we get to note
too many dead here uh could you make it
two bodies
so so we made it to it two bodies
covered by sheets lie in the street
the only reason for changes like this is
because
you know there are these morons out
there in the non-violence
pta committees who are counting bodies
and the count just went down by two
so it makes them look a little better it
doesn't make television any less
significantly violent
this is a background shot a bunch of
bodies lying in the
in this you know a bunch of sheeted
forms in the street is that going to
have
any significant effect on you know or
what we're teaching our kids or our
culture that there's two instead of four
no but it's the kind of hypocritical
game that the network standards and
practices people play
china moon uh which i was getting to uh
well first of all we had to cut down the
bodies we had
this chinese tong invades the tunnels
and the climax of that you know and
you know the guy goes down with a whole
bunch of men you know so and vincent
kills them all
and they said too many men you know you
have to get rid of uh you know
boy he kills 13 people could he just
kill eight people so
you know that was fine that saved on our
budget too we we uh
we didn't have to uh hire all of those
actors on stuntmen to die
but the climax of the show was all of
the underlings and the thugs have been
killed and vincent is facing
the last the chinese warlord
throws down his weapon he's he's unarmed
and he's saying you won't kill an
honorary man and the beast in vincent
is struggling with the human invention
as to whether he should kill him because
he knows if he lets him go
the guy's just going to get a bigger
army and come back
the way the plot resolved it was an
earlier stage where we
i we had what we thought was a better
notion where vincent actually does kill
him but
uh we dropped that in-house for our own
reasons and i think it was a mistake but
we did it anyway
and we arrived at a thing where uh one
of his men's is still alive and these
guys are all armed with like ninja
weapons so this guy's like coming up
behind vincent and he flings a throwing
star
vincent hears it coming and it's coming
at vincent and he ducks down and it
kills the warlord
okay so like in the first draft the
throwing star
goes into his throat you know well we
got a horrified
call from standard prank you can't you
know you can't put this
horrible thing in the guy's old man's
throat and kill him you know
cut it out you know so i was the
the writer producer who was doing the
rewrites on this it was the script was
originally by a freelancer
so i said oh all right i can't put it in
his throat okay it goes in his eye
[Laughter]
well that you should have heard that
they can't go with his eye you know so
what they insisted we did is they go in
his chest
well the only thing is if you ever see a
throwing star it's a little tiny kind of
thing you know and the chester's like
ribs and
you know a lot of stuff and getting a
throwing star in your chest
doesn't actually kill you which we
needed to be done here
but standards and practices was
completely oblivious to this point so
what we wound up saying around in-house
is well i guess the shock
must have killed him you know you know
the old man just had a massive heart
attack at that point in time when he got
the the throwing star in his chest
which nicked him slightly please notice
what's happening here with standards and
practices in this this
campaign about violence here at no point
did standards and practices ever suggest
to us
that this man not die the show was not
going to become
less violent and i certainly didn't
suggest
let's not have this big violent ending
where vincent kills all those people
they liked all that action
but they wanted you know most of the
deaths to be off stage
they wanted to make it clear that it
wasn't quite dead that was another very
amusing thing uh
in vincent's dialogue with the old
tongue leader
you know when he first emerges from the
shadows underground
and he's killed the three guys that or
or he's
attacked we haven't seen what's happened
because there's a lot of mists and
darkness
but the three guys who were with the old
tongue leader are no longer around
so the tongue leader says i have i have
other men out in the tunnels too
and vincent says all did and we got a
note from standards and practices well
this makes it very clear that he's
killed them and we don't want him to be
that violent so could you make it
you know none left
so you know i we had a lot of fun with
that so
how about fresh out you know i have
other minutes i know fresh out
none left you know what what and and
the the note also said you know and this
way it makes it clear that he hasn't um
he hasn't killed them he's just
destabilized them so for the entire run
of beauty and the beast that became a
sort of a staff joke well does it really
destabilize the hell out of that guy
i would like to get if possible to a
couple of your novels briefly
fever dream mark twain meets dracula
how did the idea come about well i lived
in dubuque iowa for a number of years in
the late 70s
dubuque is an old riverboat town it used
to manufacture steamboats it's right on
the river
and uh i i fell in love with the history
of the time
i'd always wanted to do a vampire novel
and somehow the two ideas just kind of
grew together in my head
that it should be a a period piece a
steamboat vampire now
it's similar in certain respects to uh
to the anne rice books has anybody ever
said that
yeah at the time i wrote it there was
only one of them was out
the interview with the vampire but uh
yeah there certainly are
some overlap you're gonna write a sequel
to this uh yeah i've thought about it uh
there's been a lot of requests for
sequel over the years
and i've been doing a lot of research
about 1890s new york which is another of
my favorite periods and i think i would
use that
if i if i did do uh a second book
i i think the fever dream and this
potential sequel
have great great potential for the
screen and yet
uh my perception is that historically
oriented motion pictures are very much
out of vogue is this a correct
impression
unfortunately it is yes there i think
that's uh
that is very sad uh it's even worse in
television and movies
but period pieces are considered very
expensive and they're also considered
not
tremendously commercial i had one
one studio wished to option fever dream
at one point but they wanted to make it
a
contemporary and i said hotel great yeah
what are you gonna do uh
how do you deal with the steamboats then
uh so well i have to drop that i mean or
make them exper
i mean it's not the same if you make it
a contemporary
i think that's part of the uh the
poverty of the cultural poverty of
america today
traces to that i mean i'm sure you're
all familiar with these
recent studies and books that have been
done that show that a frightening
proportion of our
of our kids can't place uh the united
states on the map of the world
or things like that and there's a lot of
criticism of the
educational institutions because of that
which they probably deserve
but i think television and film also
bear a great responsibility for this
i don't see that entertainment should be
educational
you know necessarily but when i grew up
i watch some pretty trashy
and entertaining shows that nonetheless
did educate me i mean television and
movies when i grew up
was full of all times and places there
were there were westerns
there were shows about king arthur and
robin hood you could watch rama the
jungle
and you could watch sergeant preston at
the yukon and you could watch circus boy
you had there was a show about the
foreign legion
the french foreign legion these were kid
shows
now no they may not have been
historically accurate shows you watch
them today and you
laugh at their inaccuracies and their
stereotypes and their stupidities
but nonetheless you learned like where
africa was
that there were elephants and natives
and uh
and and there and that it was cold in
the yukon and that people got around by
sled
you learned a little bit about history
and other cultures
today there's nothing nothing but
suburban american big cities
i mean it's like this country and the
television and film industry that
entertain it
want to look at nothing but their own
images in the mirror if it doesn't take
place
in in spielberg land suburban america
we don't want to see it we don't want to
even see
things that are off i mean try to sell
story about a circus today
no one wants to see that either you
can't sell that in hollywood i've
been involved in at the circus people
strange in the circus we want to deal
with normal
people the audience the normal people
audience wants to watch shows about
other normal people
it's aggravating you mentioned fever
dream as a
period piece your 1983 novel or
thereabouts armageddon reg
has also been described as a period
piece of another sort people have
referred to it as
that's george r.r martin's 60s book
everybody has to write a 60s book and
that one is his
what about that oh it is my 60s book
i don't deny that at all it's actually
set in the early 80s but uh which is
when i wrote it
contemporary setting at the time but it
reflects
very heavily on on the 60s and what we
all went through on the 60s
most particularly what i went through in
the 60s uh so
in a sense it is uh historical you wrote
dying in the light
which um struck me as being a
fascinating travelogue about a
world that's a world's fair to end all
world's fairs
and then you came out with a novel a
collaboration you wrote wind
uh windhaven fever dream armageddon rag
and some short stories some of which
were collected in tough voyaging
but after armageddon rag there were no
novels this is eight years what happened
television i mean the twilight zone i
was working on a new novel in 1985
when uh in early 86 i i got involved in
twilight zone and
twilight zone led to beauty and the
beast and um
you know that's really filled up the the
last uh
chunk of my my life i have been doing
wild cards all through that so i haven't
left prose entirely
and i've done a handful of short stories
and a novel that letter to
but television particularly if you're on
staff on a series is extremely time
consuming
and writing novels is also extremely
time consuming
each one of my novels usually took me
about a year
and i haven't had a spare year since uh
since i got involved in that side of the
industry
how do you feel about that would you
rather stay in tv as you've been or get
back to writing books or do you have
some third course planned
uh well planned is a generous word uh
i'm kind of divided on this subject i
mean prose is my first love and i would
definitely uh
never want to give it up i want to write
more books i'm going to write more
novels and short stories and so forth
but there's an excitement to television
too that i can't deny
it was fun when beauty and the beast was
on there are
rewards that you get from television
that you don't necessarily get from
books well first of all there are
tremendous financial award
rewards and anyone who says that's not a
factor i think is a liar or an idiot
you know the the pay in television is
just extraordinary
but there's also i i mean there's
there's real highs i remember the
the first television script i did which
was an adaption of
rogers laziness last defender of camelot
you know i i write the script it goes
through a couple drafts
suddenly they're building stonehenge on
the stage beside my office
you know there's there's a hundred
people working to to make this
this uh dream of roger zelazny's which
i've had the the privilege to interpret
into a reality and certain suddenly
we're sitting down and actors like
richard kiley and norman lloyd are
are saying the dialogue that i wrote
does there's an excitement to that
there's a a level of seeing your dreams
made flesh
that has an addictive quality